right-hander brad keller two wins this
year three losses and era bloated at
8.06
tim anderson right-handed hitting
shortstop
batting average 298.
wow
where did that miss no he got it oh we
got him a late call by dan bolino and
anderson can't believe it
so one on one out for
mankata
in there strike three call
so two looking so two way and up comes
jose abreu
santana holding to the runner adam eaton
2-2 pitch is swung on and miss that's a
good start for keller three strikeouts
eaton stranded it first and after half
an inning
light sox nothing royals coming up
left-handed starter carlos radon is 4-0
this year with a .72
e.r.a ben and tendy coming in on a
10-game hit streak
here comes the one-two
call strike three a slider right down
the middle froze andrew benintendi
first strikeout for carlos
that brings up zach collins
brad keller's next pitch
strike three call
so brad got the slider in the zone and
colin's caught looking it'll bring up
jorge solaire
one two from rodon
called strike three
dan molino waited a while to give jorge
solaire the bad news
hunter locked out yesterday went over
four but
here's the 3-2
high fastball appeal down
dozier got the bad news he goes down on
strikes
it'll bring up hancer alberto
hitting 218 this season 12 for 55.
1-0
inside pitch a lofted into center field
anderson will go back and make the catch
over the shoulder tim anderson what a
grab so it'll be michael a taylor
batting eighth
blew it
on the force seamer
here's nikki lopez
well
i just think if the computerized zone
makes fewer mistakes
and it won't be perfect
there will be unintended consequences of
pitches that just don't look like
strikes that'll be called strikes
as rodon just picked up number five nine
batters in
no score top of the fourth adam eaton
will lead off against brad keller eaton
the only man to reach he walked with one
out in the first inning but
keller followed up with strikeouts of
mankato and abreu
and then how about that play by hanzer
alberto
beautiful defense
so two on for the
first time tonight
for either club and the batter is jorge
soler
collins flashes the signs still
scoreless here bottom of the fourth
rodong brings it home it gets him
swinging on a slider
now dozier he's in right
see what brodan and collins have planned
here another 3-2 called strike three
[Applause]
seventh of the night on a heater from
rhode we are still scored mercedes d.h
tonight leading off the fifth inning in
a scoreless game one base runner for the
white sox a one-out walk in the first
inning
2-2 pitch
and a wave and a miss and a strikeout of
your mean mercedes
brad keller with his
fifth strikeout on the night
we'll bring up the left-handed hitting
catcher zach collins he is 0 for one
tonight struck out looking in his first
chance
keller brings the 1-2 home swung on and
lifted into center field back goes
taylor at the track at the wall it is
gone
home run for zach collins and the white
sox take the lead at one to nothing
4 30 to deep center field for zach
collins madrigal flied to right his
first time up
here's another 2-2
fastball got him swinging that was up
and out of the strike zone at 95
and that's keller's sick strikeout now
adam eaton
anderson away from second base keller
looking back 2-0 pitch line shot to left
it's down anderson is coming around
third here's the slide he is safe
and rbi for adam eaton as anderson was
flying
it's an rbi for adam eaton and a two
nothing sox lead
[Applause]
two down for jose abreu
we've seen some at bats where jose looks
as locked in as he
can be but it's it's not been
two three four games in a row quite yet
for 2020's mvp
the one-two pitch
swung on and lifted into left center
field
it's gonna get down at the base of the
wall
taylor's got it eaton will come around
third and score a brayu an rbi double
and the sox have a three-nothing lead
mercedes has grounded to third
and struck out
the pitch
swung on that's line to deep right
dozier goes into the corner and he
slides and makes the play just inside
the line
that ball off the bat of a right hand
hitter just continued to fade away from
him but
dozier runs it down that saved another
run
chicago gets two
and in tandy is 0 for 2. he struck out
looking in the first and fly to right
2-2 pitch fastball line to right it is
snagged by eaton on the dive
salvi has
two of the four hits tonight and both
have come on an 02 pitch
how about salvador perez he's three for
three off of
carlos rodon tonight
and all three have been laser line
drives
a little friendly competition here okay
he hits this ball
and rodon look look at him rodon says
ah
i gave you one there
so that's a man on first now two out in
the inning for jorge solaire
seven strikeouts on the night so far
for number 55 carlos ferdinand here's
the 3-2 cut it a miss he got him
strikeout number eight
adam eaton has driven in one of the runs
and he has scored a run
here's the o2
it is a swing and a miss at a slider
so eaton is down on three pitches
and the white sox leave the bases loaded
in the seventh inning so two on two out
and up comes
billy hamilton
here's the 2-1 pitch and it sliced left
field on the run ben attendee he got
there foul territory
and again the white sox get a lead off
walk that are turned aside 2-2 pitch
from urban santana
chopper over second base
quit slides scoops throws safe at first
good effort that was a tough play
looking at the replay
looks like he was out
and they have called him out and now
it's adam eaton
two balls one strike
then comes the pitch
and a high fly ball twisting toward foul
ground
and ben and tendy into foul territory to
make the play
and in the inning
this three-nothing lead for the sox
[Applause]
is in danger
nikki lopez will bat
lopez
a lefty low two swung on lifted into
center field
anderson back out makes the catch and
the white sox win it